[Music]
graduation time for the raf's newest
offices
but anyone hoping to become a pilot may
have up to a year to wait for flying
lessons to start commanders are working
to fix chronic problems with the
training system that's caused huge
delays and even prompted some recruits
to quit speaking anonymously one such
trainee Aviator told Sky News I and the
majority of aircrew are resentful at
having had our time wasted through
shoddy organization in a service that
doesn't value its personnel I'm not
alone in feeling massively let down by
senior officers after we've given up so
much personally to serve UK security
I left because I no longer had an Air
Force I was proud to serve Elite
documents seen by Sky News reveals the
mfts or military-flying training system
while improving remains under strain
of 770 trainy air crew almost two-thirds
490 people are either between courses or
on hold waiting for a slot to open up
as part of efforts to reduce log jams it
said the RAF plans to optimize the
pipeline by temporarily reducing the
inflow of trainees to EFT or Elementary
flying training
it's a move that may mean holds of up to
12 months the RAF insists that the
experience of those doing Flying
training here at cramwell and elsewhere
is finally improving that the capacity
of the training pipeline has been shrunk
over time to cut costs in line with
reductions to the size of the Air Force
it means it's less resilient and one new
shock could knock the whole system off
course again
this expert says fixing flying training
was the one priority given to the head
of the Air Force who's retiring next
week I would say that the situation that
he's passing on to his successor is is
one that he would have been very very
embarrassed to to have found when when
he took office
an RAF spokesperson said criticism of
the system focused on individual views
and historical issues ignores the
variety of proactive measures that have
been introduced and that both holding
and training times have reduced and will
continue to do so but the UK has just
announced plans to help train Ukrainian
Pilots to the RAF says this won't impact
on British flying courses others are not
so sure
Deborah Haynes Sky News